die ersten kampfflugzeuge staaten gegen
16 uhr ortszeit vom flughafen in die
abag ihr es ist der beginn einer
militäroffensive mit der präsident
erdogan seine sicherheitszone
durchsetzen will eine art puffer zu den
bewaffneten kurden milizen der gpg die
als terroristen bezeichnet
auf twitter vermeldet er unsere absicht
ist es den terror korridor an der
türkischen grenze zu beseitigen und der
region frieden und ruhe zu bringen
unterstützt von der artillerie hat die
türkische luftwaffe ziele auf einer
länge von 120 kilometern auf syrischem
boden nahe der grenze bombardiert
noch ist unklar die beiden erdogan in
das jüdische gebiet vorrücken will ich
wünsche unseren soldaten viel erfolg und
küsste sie auf die stirn sagt der
präsident als oberster befehlshaber in
den istanbuler teestuben ist der
einmarsch das thema viele unterstützen
diese operation an der türkei mehr
sicher
ok eine sicherheitszone kann es geben
aber in ein land einzumarschieren das
nicht unsere nicht klug die von kurden
dominierten zürich demokratischen kräfte
sdf haben die generalmobilmachung
verkündet rauchwolken auch auf der
türkischen seite auf die offensive haben
die kurden mit mörsergranaten
geantwortet